Okay.
Hello everyone.
My name is Jonathan Macintosh.
As Joy said,
I'm a political remix artist.
I'm an alto and activist and the grass roots style.
So I do the protest with the signs that you saw before on a number of issues,
especially around social justice and human rights in the United States.
Um,
I'm also a curator,
so I curate a,
the type of work that I do,
but that's done by others into shows.
Um,
it's what I call political remix video.
and that's what I'm here to talk about today.
Um,
political remix video I think pushes the limits of intellectual property,
um,
in ways that other remix work.
Uh,
it doesn't necessarily do.
Um,
so it's,
I think it's unique in that way and it's also part of this symposium is pushing
the limits of intellectual property.
So I think it's fitting.
Um,
oh,
the other thing that they can do this type of work I think is to create,
um,
a critical culture or help create critical culture.
Um,
I'll talk about that in a minute.
so as a quick definition,
uh,
we've talked about Remix,
we've talked about open source.
We've talked about free culture a little bit and talk about sharing a lot.
Um,
so I want to talk about what the subset is for political remix video.
so it's a process.
It's about deconstructing mass media or mass media,
fragments of corporate media or pop culture.
Um,
and then so you capture it off of TV,
off of movies,
off of music videos,
um,
off of mainstream music,
off of news cast especially.
Um,
and then you reconstruct it so you break it apart,
reconstruct it,
um,
and you create a new subversive message,
sort of use the old vehicle to create something new and put that alternative
message back out there.
And it's using the same,
the same footage,
the same forms.
Um,
so really it's a definition of subversion,
I think.
Um,
so I'm going to show you a brief example quickly.
It's easy to show you then tell you,
um,
I'm going to do this by going to my website first so you can follow along if you
have a computer.
Um,
so we are going to my website,
which just rebellious pixels here.
Me,
uh,
oh,
that's a picture of me.
Um,
I'm gonna go down here to my youtube channel,
check on it.
I also have neuro and blip.
Um,
and I'm gonna go into my ars electronica symposium for playlist,
which you can also find is open on my channel.
So you can take these videos home.
You want a watch them and I'm going to play just a small piece of what I think
is my absolute favorite political remix to date.
It was made by Jackie's Salaam.
Um,
and it is about the media,
Hollywood media,
betrayal of Arabs and Arab Americans,
but Arabs in general,
um,
in mainstream media,
mainstream TV,
movies,
uh,
mainstream blockbuster is et cetera.
Um,
so she's picking apart these,
these films and she's creating a new work.
That new work is a trailer which he calls planet of the Arabs.
Um,
and we can,
I'll show it here real quick.
I'm going to use youtube because this is how you would view it online.
This is how I view things.
So that's how we'll do it here.
Hopefully we'll have ring up.
I'm going to show a small piece of this.
The full thing is nine minutes.
You can watch this later.
I recommend that you do.
[inaudible]
that's what Walmart does.
It say what God's command is.
Americans.
It's a White House.
One day I will go,
I would drive a truck.
You have queued up.
We mean children bombed our cities from a fog like codes and you dare to call us
white sport.
I was bad.
Yeah,
it was in here.
She was in Paris showing the fall collection.
She got hit by a Bursa terrorists,
crossfire.
Palestinians,
French police.
Oh my God.
They found me.
I don't know how they found me.
Ooh.
What do you think?
Oh,
[inaudible]
there's no borders,
no cost go anywhere in the u s there's nothing to stop.
[inaudible]
I ran into another grand.
They'll you a sense of
what I'm saying.
Citizen,
he slept really well,
should be parked together.
A small segment of that.
Um,
so she's taking some park and she's,
uh,
she's saying,
look,
here's all these racist portrayals of Arabs in the media,
especially the US media.
Um,
and you know,
I've seen a lot of these movies before.
Uh,
and I,
I'd seen back in the future,
you know,
hundreds of times,
probably the child.
Um,
and it was my favorites and I never saw that.
I never saw that piece of back to the future where he screams,
here come the Libyans and they come screaming and shooting m six teens in a
suburban parking lot in the United States.
Right?
Crazy,
ridiculous,
racist portrayal of,
of Eric's.
Um,
so in this context I went,
Whoa,
now I can't look at that movie in the same way again knowing I have to think
about it in a more of a critical way.
And she does that with cartoons.
He does that with kid shows.
He does that with mainstream movies.
And as the,
as the piece gets longer and longer and you go through it,
you'll see more and more and more of those come out if you expose them to this
process of remixes.
Um,
so that's one piece that I,
that I wanted to show quickly.
Um,
uh,
yesterday,
um,
Tim print love talked about hacking and he talked about the hacking approach to
technology,
the hacking approach art and the hacking approach to life.
Um,
which I thought was particularly interesting because you could think about
political remix video as the hacking approach to watching Televi,
right?
So we're watching something,
maybe it's a mainstream movie,
maybe it's a TV show and we're thinking critically and we're saying,
wait,
what's really going on here?
We're breaking it apart and we're looking inside of it.
And then we're trying to find some way to recreate that and expose what's there.
Um,
so,
um,
political remix video,
it was only one small part of a larger remix culture that's being developed,
uh,
all over the world.
Really.
I'm especially among youth and I classify youth as people under 30.
I'm 29,
so I'm still,
yeah,
still youth.
Um,
uh,
and this is,
we talked about a lot of this stuff over the past few days.
Um,
accessibility of technology,
um,
uh,
affordability of that technology,
being able to be online and especially having access to raw video footage.
Right?
I can't sit and watch TV for weeks and weeks and weeks on end trying to get that
little snippet.
But I have youtube and I have tools like vixy or tools like to TV,
which allow me to take youtube and then remix youtube.
Um,
I also a bit too warm so I can get movies and I can remix those,
right?
So I don't have to go to the DVD store if there are such a thing anymore and uh,
and rent them or get them off of iTunes sites.
Um,
right.
So when I think about political,
the political part of political remix video,
um,
for me it's not just about governments.
It's not just about elections,
public policy,
although that's a big part of it.
Um,
but it's also about sexuality,
about race,
about gender,
about class,
about economics.
When we saw you in the last video,
it was about,
it was about race and it's about stereotypes and portrayals of,
of people.
Um,
so the other thing that it does then is it challenging social norms.
It challenges power and powerful institutions and myths about our society and
ourselves.
Um,
so just want to show another one real quick.
I'm gonna go back to my playlist and pull up another one.
This is one that I made.
Um,
it's called go army bad guys.
It is a remix of a,
of a commercial for the US army recruiting commercial for the US army.
It was played during the first few years of the Iraq invasion.
Um,
and it was directed at getting people to come in and fight in Iraq.
So that was this.
It was shown on mainstream television in the United States all the time.
Um,
especially primetime,
especially shows that youth might be attracted to.
Um,
so here,
take a look.
Hmm.
You want to be like the good guy is riding around the white hats.
No,
to be honest,
I want to be bad guys.
Bad guys at tie people up
torture.
Sure.
Kitties with the car,
battery
hair so that the good guys,
bad guys,
they're the ones
you may go back to class,
man.
Gary,
get strength for now.
I'm strength for later.
Learn more@goarmy.com.
Apologize for the small sound problem there.
But the idea is to recontextualize,
uh,
a commercial for the u s army,
what it might be like to be in the U s army.
We might have to do and especially what that might be doing to youth,
especially in America,
but around the world.
Um,
and so you have this,
this character who is really excited about going and doing all these horrible
things now.
Um,
so it's kind of an anti recruitment at incidentally,
since I made this and there are hundreds of these online that I found him
recently,
so you can go check them out.
Um,
in fact,
I don't think you can find the actual army ads on Youtube.
I think it's only remixes at this point,
or at least I couldn't find any.
Um,
so,
um,
this form is a,
it's what I would call do it yourself.
Um,
I would call a,
it's primarily by people,
for people.
And you can see that in the way that it's,
it's created not by institutions or corporations or governments by and large,
but by people who have access to some software,
a computer and access a net access.
Um,
and then it's distributed this way too.
It's distributed freely.
So it's distributed via youtube.
Um,
be a blip,
the a half a dozen other video sharing tools because it's not me.
I'm not making it for
institutions or policymakers or academics.
I'm making it for other people,
not necessarily people who agree with me,
but other people.
It's to see that and to see,
uh,
a critical take on,
um,
on that of you.
Another one.
This one has a lot,
this is a very specific,
I think two
things were happening in California a few years ago.
Um,
she may know Swarts and was the governor of California now.
and so this is a,
this is a,
he give a little bit of context since it's very local.
Um,
there was,
uh,
a gang member who had been arrested and who was being going to be put to death
can be executed.
And um,
this guy Tookie Williams,
he had spent most of his time in jail.
It's a substantial amount of time writing books to children to get them out of
gangs.
And you become an advocate against gang violence.
And He'd been very successful in this.
Um,
and so the plea was,
you know,
governance,
Schwarzenegger,
Nigga,
please don't,
don't kill this guy.
He's,
he's doing amazing work and change,
change to turn his life around and turn to the life of young people down to um,
a source negative.
Denied that and kill him.
Anyway.
So this is a video in protest of that
a wise man once said,
the death penalty is about three things,
politics,
politics and politics.
Uh,
Stanley Tookie Williams is a repeated founder of the balance clip,
stag and was convicted of no less than four murders during his 24 years in
prison.
Williams wrote several children's books about the dangers of gangs.
Trying to discourage young people from a life of violence is work around him.
Six nominations for the Nobel Peace Prize in California's Governor Arnold
Schwartzenegger chose not to spare his life,
saying Williams had murdered without remorse.
And that the continued pervasiveness of gang violence leaves one to question the
efficacy of Williams message.
So what does that mean?
It's showtime clemency.
It was rare and as much as anything a political liability.
So I'm gonna see can be seen when it's exercise by the governor as a sign of
weakness or not being top on one of the countries.
I was supposedly a great social issues.
You ass
can't do that wrong
gentlemen.
We're all feeling at this very moment.
We'll be back right after these important messages
in the 21st century.
I went to the movie and like no other can be reasoned with
no remorse.
This weapon will be called the terminator.
Yeah.
Well there's a strict ritual to executions here at San Quentin.
But this morning,
early this morning,
everything did not go precisely as planned.
It went a long time.
They seem to have trouble finding his veins.
Any appeared to grow,
frustrated,
a guard read the death warrant and the lethal drugs started to flow.
He was tried to keep his head up then laid it back down forever.
It's going to be very carefully.
Okay.
Not a terminator anymore.
Right.
Dot.
That you just can't go around killing people.
Why?
What do you mean?
Because you can't
because you just can't.
Okay.
Trust me on this.
MMM.
So,
so that video was by a remixer called the black lantern,
and you saw some of his work,
uh,
yesterday.
Um,
he also made a video.
Uh,
George Bush doesn't like black people remix about Hurricane Katrina,
so some fantastic Regenexx work there.
Um,
so should I guess I'll show you one more quickly.
This is one called George W.
Bush has down help jam and this one is by Aaron Velazquez.
I'm taking a week commercial and attend their week commercial and remixing it
with,
uh,
the grammatical creativity of my current president.
Cool
families.
Just where a nation where Wayne's take drain.
If you don't say ever something,
you don't stay branding
uhmm
shame on.
Shame on you
can't get fooled again.
This war and the defeat of the terrorist and told a territory totalitarians and
a victory for the cause of freedom and liberty
in my state or my state of the union,
our statement,
my speech nation.
I know the human being and fish can coexist peacefully.
We've never been able to confirm any connection between the and nine 11.
Okay.
So it's a couple of things that I find really interesting about these videos.
One is it's use of pop culture.
Now I think that for political remix video,
especially the use of pop culture is,
is vital to being able to make something like this.
And why is that?
Well,
I think that for better or for worse,
pop culture,
especially pop media culture in the United States anyway,
um,
is a language that people understand.
Most people understand and it has a lot of meaning for people sort of infused
into that,
into that media.
Um,
it teaches us about ourselves,
about others,
um,
for good and for bad,
and about our society.
So it's,
it's,
it's a way that we learn through pop culture in some way that we understand the
world and it's the way that we were able to share the world.
Did you see the show last night?
Did you see what happened on the,
on the news?
Did you see this?
Do you see that right?
These are the conversations we have all the time,
at least where I come.
Um,
so it's pop culture and media and mass media are constantly constructing these
myths about who we are.
Uh,
and normalizing,
normalizing the things around us,
right?
So sexism is very normalized in mass media,
culture,
violence or power,
et cetera.
Um,
and so we can take those that,
that logic and we can break it apart and we can say,
hey,
maybe we have a different opinion about this.
Maybe we don't want to see the world in this way.
Let me expose,
let me show it,
uh,
by remixing what you are trying to feed us.
So I think pop culture is not like this magical thing that just happens.
It's a,
it's a very carefully constructed and manipulated thing.
And you know,
we might,
it might be conscious or unconscious,
but remixers can intervene in that culture,
uh,
and challenge it and create a new culture and alternative culture that says
something else with a different meaning.
Um,
uh,
the only thing that I find very interesting about those last two,
especially,
uh,
for me is the form and the style.
So you'll notice the form and the style of both of those mimic mimics mass media
culture,
right?
They Mimic TV ads,
they mimic music videos,
they mimic movie trailers,
they make the quick cuts and the sound bytes,
all the things,
all the devices that mass media uses to tell us a different story.
So just by taking them and changing the place,
uh,
you get a whole different message in a whole different meaning now.
And it also uses humor and irony and sensationalism.
All the things that TV ads use,
all the things that mass media uses and on it.
So it's not critiquing the mass media forms and styles as much as this
particular messages in them.
And I think that's a key component of remix,
especially political,
well specifically political remix video is that it's not just remixing media,
it's not just taking footages and audio and remixing that and come up with
something new.
Certainly there's a lot of that out there.
I think it's great,
but the political part for me comes when you're mixing the message also.
So the message is coming is coming at you from the mainstream saying this,
this and this and you can take it and you can change the message.
So you're mixing the message as well as the media.
And I think that is what political remix video does.
So well in my opinion,
I want to show another one.
This one also has a lot of uh,
context that's local to the u s elections.
Um,
so I'm going to give this a tiny,
very,
very small synopsis of this video because I think it needs that context in the
United States.
Incidentally,
you don't really have to talk about it cause everyone knows somehow.
Um,
cause this is all the maximum you talked about for months.
this is Jeremiah Wright.
He is the pastor of Barack Obama who was the Democratic nominee for president.
He has some very critical things to say about US foreign policy.
Um,
the mass media and mass news organizations took little clips,
little nine second clips of what he had to say and play them out of context and
condemned him universally,
right?
So much so that Barack Obama then condemned him as well for these statements.
Um,
so people like me went,
well,
I want to know what else he said.
Like,
did you know,
was it just that nine second thing?
And then he got off the stage or,
well,
no,
it's a whole sermon.
It's,
it's 30 minutes.
And this,
uh,
so this remix or whose name is Theodore Lyons,
he took a big segment about a two minute segment.
We can never heard on the mass media and played it in context.
And then over it he played,
uh,
clips from,
especially from blockbuster Hollywood movies,
things that we know,
we understand,
we're familiar with.
We can go,
oh,
I have a connection to that and emotional connection.
Cause I saw that in a theater because I liked that movie and he played that over
these words to give us some sort of context and some sort of familiarity with it
because we haven't seen this footage of,
uh,
Jeremiah Wright before,
but we have seen the things he put over it for the most part.
Um,
and I think it's a very powerful piece.
So with that context
mix scene when he got silenced by Elijah,
Mohammad was in fact true Americans.
Chickens
are coming home to roost.
We took this country by terror away from the Sioux,
the Apache,
the Roi,
the Comanche,
the Arapahoe,
the Navajo terrorism.
We took Africans from their country to build our way of ease and kept them in
slavery and living in fear,
terrorism.
We bombed the Grenada and kill innocent civilians,
babies,
nonmilitary personnel.
We bombed the black civilian community of Panama with Stealth bombers and killed
unarmed teenager than timeless pregnant mothers and hardworking father cause we
bomb Qaddafi's homes and killed his child hood bash your children.
We found the route.
We killed unarmed civilians trying to make a living.
We bombed the plant in Sudan for the attack clone.
I embassy killed hundreds of hard working people,
mothers and fathers who Lebron Nicole that day,
knowing that they never get back home.
We Bomb Nagasaki and we fight him off and then the thousands in New York.
And I ended up it out and we never batted an eye.
Kids playing in the playground monitors picking up children after school.
So failure,
not soldiers,
people just trying to make it day by day.
We have supported state terrorism against the Palestinians and black South
Africans and how we are in debt because it's done overseas.
And now brought right back into our own front.
Yeah,
America's chickens coming home to roost.
Uh,
so again,
that's theater where lions and uh,
it's called the full title is Jeremiah Wright painting a picture of you.
It's aggressive.
It's hard to find on youtube,
but if find it in the playlist.
So again,
here's,
here's something that you didn't see in the mainstream media,
at least in the United States.
He did not see that full clip down here.
Hear it.
Um,
and now we can hear that and we can have these emotional triggers that,
you know,
whatever you think about it,
it's,
it's a,
it's a different point of view.
It's something that should have been shown or heard at least,
and it wasn't.
Um,
and so remix was able to do that and use this for this familiarity.
That last clip was from a terminator.
Um,
and so we are familiar with that.
Even though we're not familiar with the words.
Um,
so I think it's very powerful,
um,
that,
uh,
critically though,
what you'll notice is that none of this can be with permission.
I don't think most of it cannot be with permission.
I don't know if the owner is of that media,
those movies,
those TV shows are going to be like,
yeah,
cool.
Go ahead and use it,
remix it,
you know,
have this political message critical of the United States and use our movie to
do it right.
That's not going to happen.
I don't think that's going to happen for $1 million or more than a million
dollars.
And I don't think there's any way they're going to say,
yeah,
that's okay.
Um,
and so in this case,
it has to be without permission.
And that's what most political remix is,
is it's taking something without permission.
And I'm using it.
I'm taking pop pop culture.
A specialists at creative Commons is fantastic,
especially if you're looking for music and your,
you want to create something that you need to,
you want to put out there and sell or,
or whatever.
Um,
but I think that there's a,
there's something to be said of value in also being able to use elements of the
pop culture,
which is all around us,
which is part of us,
which informs who we are and use that as well to tell stories and to especially
to criticize it.
Um,
so I can't imagine that Coca Cola,
uh,
saying,
yeah,
it's cool if you go and use our logo and our commercial to criticize the running
of the Olympic torch,
who to Tibet.
No way in the world in a million years is cooking to be like,
that's cool.
Right.
But we can do that anyway.
We don't have to ask permission,
I think.
Um,
so,
you know,
is it legal?
Is it not legal as question that I get a lot.
It's fuzzy.
Um,
there's a thing called fair use in the United States,
which a lot of people have been using as a defense to something similar here.
I think.
Um,
it is,
it,
is it all fair uses it not,
I think that's up to really,
it's up to courts to decide that.
And I,
I'm not going to wait around and say if a judge will give me a stamp of
approval,
but we're,
I'll talk about my culture and the things that are happening in my life,
in my country,
um,
in this way.
Um,
so I say just do it and see what happens.
I think the value of the work is way more important than the potential legal
consequences.
Um,
especially since it might make the copyright owners a little bit angry to have
their work used in various ways that they don't agree with it.
A very highly charged and political and emotional.
Um,
so,
um,
let me just make sure we have time to move on.
Um,
so it creates,
I think it critical culture and this is something that I wanted to sort of end
on.
Um,
the power of this kind of work is not necessarily that the work will change the
society in a,
you know,
I'd made this and therefore this changed.
It's a small piece of a much larger,
um,
political and cultural transformation.
I think that's occurring.
Um,
so little tiny pieces.
So this video is a piece that's been used,
a piece,
this blogs a piece,
right?
And all those things together create a torrent of I think,
transformation and change.
Um,
so,
uh,
I'm going to show a lastly,
I'm going to show one that I made.
Um,
I want to show though the original before I show you the remix.
So hopefully this will work.
This is the original.
This is a,
um,
so I made this a few months ago.
Um,
I was watching TV or just sitting there watching TV,
you know,
surfing the channels and I saw a commercial,
which is part of a campaign by Chevron Oil Corporation and they're trying to
rebrand themselves as a human environmentally conscious company.
They're spending $15 million,
something a lot about that to estimate a on their campaign to make me believe
that this company really has my best interest at heart.
Um,
and so I saw this on TV and I went,
oh,
that's,
you know,
I'm thinking critically about it.
I'm going,
wait,
what?
Seriously.
So then I did some research.
I went to Wikipedia,
I went to blogs,
I know around around the country,
human rights blogs,
um,
courtwatch blogs.
And I found it all this information about Chevron genuine a little bit about,
but not all of it.
Uh,
they're the,
one of the last companies that's in,
um,
or one of the companies that profit in the most out of a burner working with the
dictatorship.
They,
I some pretty horrific or our environmental destruction,
both in the Niger Delta and also in South America.
Um,
there are also profiting off of a rock and the patient abroad.
these are things are not going to tell you when they're commercial,
but I was able to find with these tools we have,
so here's their version of what they are as a company.
Oh,
can you see it too?
175 miles off the coast of Louisiana.
Oh,
what's your commute?
Your flight to Phoenix.
Your way of life?
Yeah.
More than 28,000 feet below the surface
in a place that experts thought impossible to reach,
setting half a dozen world records for technological innovation without a single
safety or environmental incident.
Every day the world demands more energy and every day it gets harder to find.
So every day we push technology,
we seek alternatives,
and we also attempt the extraordinary to power the world.
Right now,
this is the power of human energy.
That's their version.
That's their version,
their version.
It obviously they have a lot of resources.
One of the biggest oil companies in the world,
they spent 15 million,
something like that on this campaign.
Um,
it's a lot of resources.
It's not a power there.
I've institutional power and ha high end guy with a computer.
So what can I do?
Um,
well,
one is I saw that name.
I went,
oh seriously.
I mean,
no,
come on.
Um,
and so,
uh,
I decided to make my own version.
I think their tagline,
human energy is very unfortunate for them.
I don't know if they vetted that through the remixing
liabilities,
but here's my version of that same APP.
Oh,
every day.
The world demands more energy.
Every day it gets harder to find.
Where is it?
How do we find it?
We were trying to answer those questions in ways unimaginable.
Oh,
can you see it
in a place that experts thought impossible to reach to?
Every day we push technology.
Tell us it can't be done then watch this.
We tap is the greatest source of energy in the world.
Oops.
This is the power of human energy.
I noticed you all didn't applaud for the,
uh,
Chevron one,
the original one.
I wonder why that is.
I wonder if that's because you're thinking critically.
Um,
I wonder if that's because we're trying to promote,
hopefully through all of this technology,
a critical culture that looks at the world around us in a critical way.
Looks at pop culture,
looks at advertising,
looks at the powerful institutions around us and says,
wait,
let me look at this.
What's really happening here?
Let me see what's,
let's break it apart.
Let's hack it.
Let's see what's inside.
Let's see how it works and let's put it back together and say,
well,
we think it might really mean,
certainly I'm talking from a best case scenario.
There's a lot of video out,
there's a lot of remix video about political topics that isn't necessarily
great,
right?
Maybe something that you hate it don't,
don't agree with.
I think that the key component is as long as it's critical of power in some way
or oppressive institutions or mainstream media,
as long as it's critical of that,
it's positive,
right?
And it helps us develop our critical analysis too.
So just in closing here it,
it,
it's,
this is not just being critical,
right?
It's not just being critical of what we see,
but it's also being creative because we can be critical of what we see and we
can think to ourselves,
well,
how can I make something out of that that says,
when I think,
all right,
so its subversion is taking their thing and saying,
I want this to say something else.
And the creative process of deconstructing it and then reconstructing it and
just something else,
like a remix video.
Um,
I think it's very powerful.
It's part of this tech talk back culture.
Uh,
it can expose oppression and expose injustice,
expose hypocrisy.
It can even empower our collective imaginations.
I think.
Um,
there's a video on this playlist,
which I would invite you all to go and see.
A,
it's called Bush for peace.
We don't have time to watch it now.
Um,
but it's a great example,
I think,
of helping us envision a better world by showing George W.
Bush give a speech for peace by re cutting his speech and putting it back
together.
So he's actually saying things that you could only dream of a president saying.
Um,
and so I think that,
uh,
that's a fantastic version of,
of remix and talking about collective imagination.
Um,
so I think I'm gonna stop there.
If you have questions,
please ask them.
And,
uh,
thank you for inviting me.
[inaudible].